"Four score and seven years ago, our fathers brought forth..."
Teachers have to answer millions of questions.
How big is outer space?
Where did my sister come from?
Is the sun following me?
Teachers have to deal with every type of emergency.
No one is gonna know that you had an accident.
Okay, let's wrap this around you here.
Teachers have to know everything about everything.
Give it a second.
So in a way, this is a very realistic portrayal of a volcano...
...'cause everybody thought it was gonna explode, but it didn't explode.
Teachers ought to be like a courtroom judge.
They must be honest and fair.
I'm gonna read you the answer you put on your math test.
"I forgot to study last night."
"Here's a drawing of a donkey wearing roller skates."
It's a good drawing, but you gotta study.
In conclusion, teachers have the hardest job in the world.
What amazing things did your teacher do for you?
Tree is here, yes.
Mr. Jeffries!